I had a car the economists deputy editor
hello my name is Callan Williams I'm
senior economics writer at the economist
and I am joining ed to answer your
questions on this call I'd like to think
that's what would happen I'm not sure it
is what's going to happen and partly
because I think we're going to go
through a very very difficult time in
the economy and big economic disruptions
tend to unsettle politics and to create
grievances and resentments the second
thing is a context in which this
pandemic struck and it's it's one in
which the post Second World War
order is breaking down where China is
clearly the rising power where the
United States certainly under Donald
Trump has either the less willingness or
capacity to be able to play the role of
sort of of overarching power who is
prepared to get involved all over the
world to try and sort out people's
problems and I think that sort of sense
of a world that's slightly falling apart
and a more rival hrus world where the
United States is worried about Chinese
power the pandemic has comments hit hit
the world and just when those those
issues are becoming more intense and so
I I think I fear that it makes them
harder to solve rather than easier to
solve
[Music]
his era of globalization was very much
slow and long before the Kovach pandemic
came along and that was only partly
related to the election of Donald Trump
it was slowing even before he became
president and I think that was that was
a kind of lingering after effect of the
financial crisis but you know what the
historical experience tends to show is
that crises tend to kind of reinforce
pre-existing trends and antique
globalization was one of them the
financial markets are hoping on this
idea of a v-shaped recession and that's
the idea that you know in one quarter or
perhaps in two quarters GP will decline
by perhaps a you know an astonishing
amount but because lockdowns will come
to an end people will make up for lost
time and you'll see a quick rebound back
to where we were at the beginning of
2020 I think what people are now
starting to wonder is whether that
really is going to happen and in
particular they're looking at what's
happening in China which began to ease
its lock down in kind of late February
in March and at the moment I mean it's
certainly the case that economic
activity has has recovered from its lows
but it's still a long way off the
Chinese economy is running at about 90%
capacity or compared with what was up
before the pandemic hit and that's
really for a few reasons
you know what seeing is that people are
going back to the office and going back
to the factory and all that kind of
stuff basically because they have to but
what they're not doing is going out and
having really spending the money having
a good time
investing in big things and what that
means is that the sort of supply-side of
the Chinese economy has it has in a way
got back to normal but there's a the
demand side hasn't and that means that
unemployment is going to probably be
persistently quite high in China for
quite a long time so if people working
in restaurants in bars in shops and all
that kind of thing there just isn't
really demand for their services and so
I think what you're going to start to
see now is as you know various American
states start to loosen down loosen their
lock down so now of course as Europe
starts to come out a lot
I think it's very unlikely we're going
to get back to where we were at the
beginning of this year first effects of
this disease was interruption supply
chains and I think that might remain
with companies in that they might
diversify their supply chains and that
was kind of happening anyway because
China is becoming a more expensive place
to manufacture things as against that
supply chains have a strong driving
force for getting costs down and of
being optimized and they're they're
pretty intolerant of inefficiencies and
so that will still sort of be pushing
very strongly in the other direction I
guess one thing I might add today is to
think about the financial system and
about how that world you know that's
part that's part of a supply chain to
you know how a power company is able to
access finance in order to start
producing stuff what you're seeing now
really across the world is really
unprecedented levels of uncertainty and
so I think what you could see is that
you know financing new projects and
getting people to commit to projects
could actually become very difficult and
this is starting to show up in the data
now where if you look at surveys of
managers you know they're asked what are
your plans for investment and so on
they're much much lower now than they
were even in the absolute depths of the
financial crisis of 2008 9 and and back
bear in mind back then you know some
people really thought the financial
system was going to come to a complete
stop
[Music]
it's held up a mirror to them to the to
the most vulnerable aspects of society I
mean you know Singapore is a great
example of that you know it's a country
that apparently had dealt with the the
outbreak extremely well and then a few
weeks down the line there's you know
there's huge outbreaks in the in the
migrant labor camp that keep the
Singaporean economy going and there are
the kind of seedy underbelly of the
Singaporean economy and people there
have very poor access to health care and
of course there are still millions of
people who are uninsured in the US and
you know there's there are worries that
those people and though that you know
particular people lose their jobs that
people will be less willing to go
forward for testing and and so on so I
think what you could see and this
perhaps would be one of the biggest you
know upsides of the whole pandemic is
there the idea of you know a universal
access to health care that's free at the
point of use could could start to become
common sense in all countries so I think
the pandemic will make States more
powerful if you look back at you know
centuries of really of Western history
there's sort of two lessons that emerged
about the power of states one is that
they it tends to increase over time as a
kind of background effect and the second
is that states tend to become a lot more
powerful both during and after
immediately after periods of crisis you
know normally in a recession what
happens is that the state it doesn't
like saying this but it it kind of
accepts that in a recession businesses
will go bust and people will become
unemployed and it says that's okay
because the idea is that you want to you
know reallocate people and capital and
all that kind of stuff from areas that
were failing to areas that are up and
coming and that's how it normally works
but what's happened in this time is that
states of governments and politicians
are saying basically if we can we want
to avoid all bankruptcies and we want to
make sure that nobody becomes unemployed
what that does is it opens the door to
really significant government
intervention in the economy going
forward so you know let's imagine that
in a few years where we've moved to move
beyond
this pandemic but of course there will
be another recession at some point down
the line I think if it's generally
accepted that the government did a
pretty good job during this crisis of
protecting jobs and protecting firms
then people will say well heaven if it
worked last time then why not do it
again so I think we could see quite
radical changes in sort of expectations
of what the state should do and what the
state thinks it's legitimate for it to
do you often hear people say that one
thing at least good thing that's come
out of the pandemic is that has been
good for the climate you can calculate
you know how many hundreds of thousands
of tons of carbon dioxide haven't been
put into the atmosphere because there
have been fewer flights and so forth and
I suppose there is a sort of
demonstration effect you know people
might you know this is in the sense
something that doesn't normally happen
but as against that you know a poorer
world a world that has less inclination
to invest and a world as worried about
unemployment and life and death is a
world that I think is less inclined to
invest in the transformation of you know
the world to a sort of carbon free
economy there's one big wrinkle on that
however which is the oil industry the
price has collapsed
countries in the Middle East Russia
Venezuela that depended upon oil is a
very important the main source of their
foreign exchange earnings are suddenly
finding that they are getting enough
money to do the things they want to do
oil companies are beginning to see that
perhaps the oil price might not recover
for a very long time that also is giving
people a sort of incline and a glimpse
that there may be a future without oil
which is a very important component of
the transition to
away from a carbon-based economy I mean
it's gonna become more distant I suppose
in the sense that I think you know if
you're gonna have a meeting with someone
and face-to-face you know for the
foreseeable future there has to be a
pretty worthwhile meeting so I think the
idea of going for a speculative coffee
with someone well seen at least for a
while kind of weird
you're only your you'll reserve your
your ventures out of the house for
people that you sort of know you're
going to have a productive time with so
I think that will potentially you know
reduce the exchange of ideas and that
kind of thing and I think the same goes
for for travel business travel and
research travel and so on you know if
you look at what's happened say in the
scientific community and in economics
most papers research papers now most
research projects involve
a large team of people and also a
growing proportion of those projects
evolve people in more than one country
you know normally that might be the
America or Canada but you do get an
incredible diversity in cooperation and
I think that if you know meeting people
and traveling becomes harder you can see
a really really big hit to innovation
and patenting and all that kind of stuff
[Music]
probably quite a lot so we did a we did
a analysis a couple of weeks ago looking
at the countries which countries that
we're going to be most affected
potentially by by their by the turn down
and if you look at the very top of the
ranking so the countries most affected
they are true and dependent economies
Greece comes
unfortunately right at the top and then
Italy and Spain are printing in the top
as well and Turkey also is very high up
there particularly in Europe to tourism
ministers are starting to talk to each
other and say you know how can we make
this work if Greece doesn't have a
tourist season this year this summer its
economies and is in really really
serious trouble so what I expect you'll
start to see is people thinking you know
pretty creatively about what they might
do so if you take the example of Israel
earlier this week they said the hotels
could reopen but you could only stay on
the ground floor I actually remain
fairly optimistic about saying the
prospects that people will be able to to
travel and so on I think it it might
become something is open to fewer people
you know if if the flight from say
London to Spain is only allowed to be
two-thirds full because of the required
social distancing then that means the
ticket prices will have to go up and so
it would be available to fewer people
but my sense is that because this is
such an important issue for some
countries that is there people will find
a way of making this work if it's all
possible if you'd like to sign up -
why's that - better on coronavirus for
more updates click the link opposite and
thank you for watching
you